what up vlog um this is a keynote game
in oslo a couple weeks ago
super excited about it uh really felt
strong
uh thought a lot of uh insights that i
haven't uh touched on in the past were
extracted
uh the tremendous oslo oslo stand up
incredible crowd in oslo uh extracted uh
some interesting insights and i hope you
enjoy it real state of the union where
my mind is at
when it comes to attention and framework
and strategy around
how to succeed enjoy enjoy enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
oslo
um i love you back bro
it's always good when you bring your
brother to a talk
so you know i love this format i really
appreciate this format the
give a talk then we'll do some q a
together then we'll bring you guys in
and so
what i want to accomplish in part one
here is to create a framework of
some of the things that may inspire some
questions in detail
when we get to that part i think what
excites me
more than anything as i sit here this
morning is that we are living through
such an interesting time
one that i think is quite binary i'm
curious what's going through uh people's
minds as a matter of fact real quick
because i
asked some questions did a little
homework how many people here are in the
b2b business
raise your hands so this is exciting for
me because that's quite a bit
and it was interesting what i was
thinking about in my flight last night
i i think that there's a lot of
misconceptions
assumptions curiosities uh difficulties
for a lot of b2b marketers for a lot of
entrepreneurs for a lot of
consumer based companies i think it's a
very binary debate
i really think that we're in a place
right now where you either believe
in what i think is happening or you
don't and i think
i want everybody to listen that sentence
very carefully not about what's coming
not what's about to happen what's
happening
versus believing that or not and so what
i mean by that is
i believe a lot of the things that are
happening on the mobile device
and most importantly the attention
of the end consumer is not debatable
and i think that a lot of people
continue to conjure up
statements like yes gary in a couple of
years or
soon or it's coming or we can feel it
all these things that allude to its
non-reality
and to be very frank i'm not frustrated
or disappointed
to be very frank i don't give a [ __ ]
what you do
i really don't you know to me i'd love
to inspire you know when i when i give a
talk like this and i see all these faces
my really big hope is that one person
sees something
in the words that are said today that
makes them take this more serious
mainly to be very honest with you from a
selfish place that i want you to email
me in three years and say in 2017
you were in oslo you said this about b2b
marketing on linkedin
i finally listened and this happened i
live a life where i get hundreds of
emails a day
from entrepreneurs b2b companies
corporations i had a guy fly into a wine
tasting i did for my family business
last week
his company went from 300 000 to 60
million in sales in 18 months
on the back of facebook ads and
instagram influencers
i wish on all of you the feeling it
feels like when you actually do
something nice for another human being
when you ask for nothing in return and
you can build to your point
that legacy my friends i have no vested
interest
in this technology revolution i was
super happy pre-internet i'm old
right i turned 42 in a couple weeks i
lived pre-internet i am not a
technologist
i didn't own a computer until i was 18
years old i don't give a [ __ ] about
gadgets
i don't like vr i don't like ar i don't
like facebook
i only like one thing attention
and so obviously it manifests as a human
being and i like this feeling
and i'm more comfortable right now doing
this than even in any other environment
but more importantly i like attention
much more on a macro
where do our customers spend their time
and how do we create in those
environments
to create the thing that we want i
started vaynermedia seven years ago not
with the intent to build an agency and
sell it to a holding company
i built it because i want to build a
communications death star
so that i can point it with any ambition
i have whether that's to sell a sneaker
whether that's to raise money for my
brother's crohn's disease
whether that's to help a friend become
the mayor of new york in 20 years
whether that's to sell a t-shirt a
bottle of wine it's agnostic
it's agnostic ultimately it's going to
be to
use it for propaganda to make everybody
in america a new york jets american
football fan
but for the time being i continue to
hone these skills
i sit here today believing in alexa
skills
and amazon's big push for alexa and
google home and the future apple homepod
i believe in that space not because it's
showing
roi today but my intuition on consumer
behavior tells me in 36 months and 48
months
every single person here is going to
interact with an ai based
speaker or device and do search queries
and buy products and interact in that
environment
we are living through my friends let's
take a step back we are living through
the biggest shift in the way humans
interact with each other
since the printing press this internet
thing is a big deal
this is not about facebook or twitter or
instagram or snapchat
this is about the internet is finally at
true scale
and we're starting to really understand
its impact
and it's having obviously geopolitical
impacts
and i just feel that the audacity
amongst the b2b environment and ge is a
client
and we do things with sap and i'm a
startup investor in tons of sas
businesses and b2b business i think
there's a gross
misunderstanding on how much commerce
and actual business results happen in
the new environments
in a b2b world and let me explain the
trick
for the b2b players in this room is that
they have to understand the cadence
on how they have to communicate in this
new environment that completely
differentiates
from the way that you would communicate
as a consumer product
for example the way i think about the
haves and the have-nots
the binary people that believe or don't
believe right now
in this environment plays out in a
different way i call
it headline readers versus practitioners
there's a lot of people here who've read
an article or two
who've talked to some people over dinner
and have enormous opinions
on what facebook or linkedin or
instagram
or blogging or a podcast can do for
their business
yet they've never executed a single
podcast
never ran a single facebook ad and have
never tried segmentation
creative and media executions in a
linkedin environment
the reason i keep a garyvee brand
besides the fact that i love attention
is because i need to be a practitioner
in the green room before i came out here
i literally posted on
instagram and thoughtfully thought about
the hashtags
that i was going to use to make sure
that people discovered it i
pondered the copy that was going to
support
the video that i was putting out i
watched the video
three times to catch the energy that i
thought
i thought about the time it was in new
york city
this morning and that la would not see
it because it was going to be too early
and more of my european fans
would the depth of thoughtfulness on
timing and creative and cadence
that i thought about a single instagram
post
is completely pooh-poohed by the modern
b2b
environment it is not thought about
at any kind of strategic level and the
reason that most people
fail in winning in social media
is because of a couple of huge
misconceptions number one
there is no social media social media
is a slang term that we came up with for
the websites and apps
now that dominate the end consumer's
attention in our society
if you're willing to look at social
media the word the way i
am which is the apps
that live on the cell phone that have
most of the attention of the human race
and is the current
state of the actual internet all of a
sudden
social media doesn't feel so small or a
sprinkle
or a nice to have or the thing that is
coming
number two i just don't think people
think it's a craft
or a strategy or an art to the way that
i do it as far e
as somebody who's run television run
print
built his family's liquor store business
on the back of email
and google and somebody who's lived in
marketing
every day for the last 20 years there's
been nothing more
complicated or difficult to be
successful in than social because
especially in a facebook and linkedin
environment where the action for this
room is
it is the birth child of television
and direct mail and google all in one
platform
most people in the world of business
today have not
quantified the difference between
marketing and branding
and sales most people either sit on the
side of
math and are quant based marketers or
sit on the side of art and are creative
subjective
marketers and they don't realize that
the mix of the two and the discipline
to respect the tension of both sides in
today's environment
is the brilliance and need to be
successful
and so somebody who has been a
practitioner and attacking that skill
set
not only for myself but for the biggest
brands in the world
on the back of an 800 person agency
that does all quant and qual work
i have a very unique perspective and i'm
very intrigued by it
i'm very intrigued by how many people
think it is better
to spend money on a print ad in a b2b
magazine
than it is to run facebook ads i'm
intrigued by so many people here that
are
so much quicker to spend for the eighth
year in a row
25 000 euros to sponsor a [ __ ]
conference
instead of running twenty five thousand
dollars of linkedin ads
against the employees of companies that
they're trying to reach
with creative that would actually make
them intrigued or inspired to do
business with you
i am super intrigued by the fact how
many people here
in the own their own business raise
their hands
and how many do not fantastic
i'm intrigued by the difference of those
two groups
i live in a world right now which is
broken up between silicon valley madison
avenue
entrepreneurs and corporates i like them
all very much i love all people
and i especially love all business
people but it is not
the second group of hands fault the
employees it is impossible you're a
human being it is impossible
for you to spend the money of the
company as if it was your own
it's just not humanly possible it's just
not the way we're wired
and i watch every day two very distinct
things happening in the market today
entrepreneurs or people that own their
own business
every day moving ungodly amounts of
money into influencers
into facebook into linkedin and not into
and be careful here i am not a
traditional versus digital debater
for example i believe that most of the
money spent today on digital
is going directly in the garbage because
most of the money in digital today
is spent on programmatic banner and
pre-rolls
on websites that nobody's paying
attention to
and there's no context for the creative
it's just hitting the cpm value
or the impression value has nothing to
do with driving the business results so
this is not a
traditional media's dead digital is here
i have more issues with most
digital it's about today
it's about day trading attention it is
you are trying to sell jet engines or
shipping supplies or a sas business
and you have ten thousand dollars to
make that happen
what are you gonna do with it and to me
that's when you need to understand the
day trading of attention
what's underpriced and overpriced
attention if you're in america
and you want to sell product to an under
30 year old kid
a pair of sneakers snapchat should have
50 of your money
regardless of how good of a deal
snapchat stock is
because that's the end consumer's
attention and so
we're living through a time where the
biggest businesses in the world
are vulnerable because distribution
of information and products have been
commoditized by the internet
the distribution of our attention or the
information to us has been commoditized
nobody here
was shooting a satellite into space
to start a tv network 20 years ago
at with that capital infrastructure and
the cameras
and the studios but literally every one
of you in your pocket right now has live
television literally for free
on facebook live or instagram live i
mean it is remarkable we have completely
taken for granted
completely taken for granted the power
that we sit on
in our hands right now the recording
that you're doing right now
used to cost tens of thousands of
dollars in equipment
literally just 30 years ago we are
completely misunderstanding where the
attention is
we are misunderstanding the single
biggest opportunity for every b2b
company here
and that is to act like a media company
not an advertiser
the biggest problem for all the b2b
companies here is is that it's hard to
advertise b2b
products and so what happens when it's
hard it becomes very vanilla
you show three people smiling in a
[ __ ] office
right and you put it on a piece of paper
on page
87 and you think something good's gonna
happen
in 20 [ __ ] 18.
this what happens i mean we know it or
you make a
flyer and you send it in the mail
and you think that's a good idea in 2018
how many people here can't wait to leave
this conference and go home and
carefully go through their direct mail
yeah so so what happens is
we have no cadence or understanding or
creative output yet
everybody here can take those same
dollars and do a six part mini series
in audio form and create a six part
documentary
in podcast form around the behaviors in
their industry
or creative that's interesting to their
users for example
i have a lawyer friend who's starting a
golf podcast
because he's trying to reach high net
worth individuals and a lot of them play
golf
he's not starting a lawyer podcast
because nobody wants to listen to that
he's starting an interest podcast as a
gateway drug
to his services because the law firm is
bringing you
the golf information and so if i can
leave with anything
if anything if i can get one of the
hands that went up
from the b2b environment in this room if
i can get one of them
to actually make the shift that in 2018
instead of spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars
on print and sponsorship and direct mail
as an advertiser we're going to look at
the digital landscape
and become a media company and bring
value and interest
to our prospective clients as a gateway
drug that would be a huge accomplishment
to make it a little less altruistic and
lofty and confusing
even if you just started writing white
papers that were not
sales release but were actually white
papers
if you get out of sales and you get into
branding
if you make a white paper about trends
in your industry
and why you're servicing them right if
you made a white paper
that was 13 pages thoughtful smart you
put energy behind it your best people
behind it
and you ran that on linkedin and
facebook against the employees
and this is how you segment in an ad
form
against the employees of the companies
that you aspire to do business with
you would see remarkable results because
what attention
is most interesting to me how many
people here have ever played in
the real estate industry in their
careers raise your hands just curious
this is interesting to me i've started
realizing huh
i'm acting and navigating this world
like i'm in the real estate business
your attention
is no different than real estate people
look at new places
new beachfront properties emerging
cities
trends within cities that make you think
the property is underpriced
all i do for a living every day is
what's underpriced and what's overpriced
and market by market what's happening in
oslo that isn't happening in new york
or what's happening in new york and one
of the great i mean unbelievable
advantages
of being in a market that is not the
united states of america
is being able to watch the trends and
understanding which ones will transfer
and not
not every app will pop in the nordics
that pop in america
however 90 of all of this that i'm
talking about
is human not cultural these are human
dynamics let me give you one
everybody here will give up privacy
for time is
the pillar asset for us besides health
money and religion time
so when i think about audio and why i
push you
to thinking about a podcast is because
if you're trying to reach
a high net worth individual or a
decision maker
in a business that would do business
with you in a b2b environment
i'm going to make the assumption that i
think we all can is that she's busy
and what audio does how many people here
follow my content raise your hands
thank you of the people that keep your
hands up i wanted the other people to
see this
thank you look around if you're in the
front okay not not no it's not enough
don't worry that's not what i'm saying
what i'm saying is watch now this okay
thank you now
of those people how many of you in the
last year have started listening more to
my podcast and watching less of my video
raise your hands that
that's what i am most intrigued by right
now to me thank you
to me the fact that technology
in 2018 and 19 is moving us as humans to
act more like people
from the 1930s to 60s and consume more
radio
because we have it on us because we are
subconsciously
trying to find more time because time is
emerging as an asset because we're
getting pounded
with information because we are starting
to get trained
we grossly underestimate the brain and
human beings we're starting to get
trained
to listen to the podcast and do
something else
and so i am betting on voice
both podcast and alexa skills and google
home
and all those skills because i know that
is
the thing we're gonna buy into one of my
great misses
in my investment career uber which i
passed on twice
in the for angel round at a four million
dollar evaluation
i invested in later at 100 million
valuation
because i realized uber wasn't selling
transportation
uber was selling the perception of time
when you hit that button you're able to
go on and do what you're doing until it
gets there
and that was the remarkable insight
so much of what you do every day the
things you value
do you know why you don't unsubscribe
from emails
that you have no interest in getting
time it takes you longer
to unsubscribe to the email than it does
to just delete it or swipe it out
time is driving so much of our behavior
and in the b2b
environment in the b2b environment
it is emerging more to me
strategically because the decision
makers were desperate to reach
value time even more and that's why they
will not go through
their direct mail that is why they will
not go through a magazine
carefully and stumble on your
advertisement can we
hustle can we make a deal can you not
buy a print [ __ ] ad next year
i mean i'm sitting here and i'm talking
and i'm like then the other part of my
brain is like yeah this is so red
how the [ __ ] you buy a print ad in 2018
it makes no sense what it's
so overpric do you know that you pay
eight to 12 times circulation
as the cpm cost for a print ad in case
jorge
leaves the magazine on the bus and susan
picks it up and goes to page 90 [ __ ]
seven and sees your ad
the lack of practicality is so obnoxious
yet
there are people here who comfortably
buy print ads because that's what we've
always done
while asking what the roi of facebook
and linkedin is
just incredible times and you will see
some of the biggest companies in the
world
over the next decade completely vanish
off the face of the earth
because of their misallocation and their
misunderstanding
of where the consumer's attention is
they will not
understand they will go out of business
this is happening
it's happening faster than you think you
see it all around the world i was in
singapore last week
the number two magazine media company
shut down its print it's happening every
single day in america toys r us the
biggest toy retailer out of business
out of business this is happening every
single day and will continue to
accelerate and i'm stunned
that i go to a dinner every night of the
week where for the first 30 minutes
a 70 year old executive will want to
talk to me for 30 minutes how
he or she cannot believe that facebook
has changed the election
in the us changed the brexit it's
unbelievable
they should shut it down we need laws
this is crazy
it's too powerful it's super scary what
about our grandchildren and then we will
transition to the 30 minutes
of the business talk and they'll say to
me but my customers aren't
on facebook
that's what i do every time too i throw
up directly on them
it's it's time it's time we have the
proper conversation
which is the following most things that
we grew up with five
years ago banner ads and pre-rolls
included
are overpriced it's not that anything's
dead
i hate when people are like t.b is dead
tv's not dead
you know radio is not dead they're
overpriced
what you pay for is not what you get
meanwhile
everybody in here will read an article
in six years that says 2012
to 2019 was a golden era facebook ads
and you should have done more and now
that they're 48 cpm instead of 7
cpm you'll regret and you'll be sad
right that's what happened to me when i
get introduced and people say he built
his dad's liquor store from three to
sixty million dollars
and everybody's like uh i get sad
because i spent too much money on print
and outdoor and radio and all the other
things
even though it was staring me in the
face that google for 5 and 10 and 11
cents a click
was driving unbelievable roi i took it
for granted
i was too young and didn't understand
how good of a deal it was
and that's why i stand passionately up
here today and tell you every penny you
can afford to put into facebook
and create videos and pictures to make
it work every penny you can afford for
the b2b players
to put into linkedin and create white
papers and videos
for them every penny you can afford
because you will go back
and look at this era much like many of
you did with google
in the early 2000s and then you did it
in 2010 and 12 and 15 and you're like
and you caught up the problem was now
you're paying the appropriate price
you're not stealing it like everybody
did from 2001 to 2006
that is what's happening either i'm
right or i'm wrong
it'll play itself out but i will tell
you this
when i see how many of you are familiar
with wish the shopping app
raise your hands wow that in itself
18 months ago if i asked that question
four hands would have put up one more
time how many of you are familiar with
wish
how many of you bought in something off
wish
[ __ ] this all makes sense listen to this
wish in the last seven years or six
years has gone from
zero zero to anywhere between three to
five
billion dollars in sales it is probably
the most emerging most important
retailer
in the world that most people don't know
yet it is a top
50 app in every single app store country
on apple in the world all of their money
all of their money into this last year
where they put
some branding on the lakers jerseys and
on the mayweather mcgregor fight in the
corner
all of their money for the last six
years has been spent on facebook
and these were engineers that were
employees from google
and left why because they saw the
pattern recognition that i saw
which was amazon amazon
was google's biggest advertiser in the
early days of google
and they used that underpriced attention
to build a monster company
and that's exactly what these wish
founders did they knew that google was
underpriced for those years
they knew that facebook was the new
underpriced model they went all in
all in and they bought underpriced
attention acquired customers that
underpriced nature and built against
that momentum
that environment is still available for
the next 24 months
for the majority of this room including
the people that are practitioners and
understand that you can target
employees of organizations on facebook
and i highly recommend that you do not
take
this talk for granted and you go back
home after today
and you start googling how do i run
facebook ads for my b2b sessions
how do i do this how do i do that the
tactics are commoditized
you can google it at home the mindset
to understand what year we're actually
living in
is the punchline of this conversation
thank you
thank you
gary my friend rick bought me this
i like this yeah it's a jet set
and i realized that it doesn't really
make any sense to give it to you okay
because you probably have a thousand
seven thousand
yeah yes but i still have it so um
should we get sign it and give it to
somebody else
that's cool yeah yeah we'll do that okay
we'll uh we'll do that okay
okay cool so sit down here please some
water red bull
we're gonna have a lot of fun with these
by the way uh it you heard about this
catchbox of course i [ __ ] speak every
day you're so trendy
[ __ ] sorry no worries
um okay so um
we are going to have a little
conversation and then you guys can
already start thinking about all the
cool questions you're going to ask but i
just want to start
so first of all welcome back to oslo
thank you how are you feeling great
yeah great thank you so much guys for
the energy really appreciated
so the room is filled with with business
people
yep um and as we talked about before we
hit the stage
um norway is quite ahead in terms of of
digital
and snapchat is bigger than instagram
here
um and and i would say the average
norwegian
uses social a lot i agree but still
um i get the vibe from the the
advertising industry that a lot of
business are still very behind
on um on investing in facebook ads
google adwords all that jazz
as you were just describing over 70 year
old
dinner meetings with 17 year olds and
you know why that is right
tell me it's not a norwegian thing it's
not a nordic thing
it's a global thing it's because the
biggest holding companies
that are the four to five biggest
holding companies in the advertising
industry
the wpp's the omnicoms the publicist
these are publicly traded companies
who should be driving their business
results not their clients results
are always selling things that they make
the most margin
on which is television and programmatic
digital
and then they will support it with
[ __ ] reports that are an inside
the game dynamic to justify the spend
and they are extracting the value out of
the biggest companies in the world
and so they feel comfortable with the
reports and the [ __ ] [ __ ] metrics
that they measure on
internal mmms and so it's a complete
inside
have you did you see the big short the
movie the big short yeah that's what's
happening in the advertising world
everybody's in on it the companies are
[ __ ] getting [ __ ]
they're going to lose the biggest media
companies
are getting bigger and bigger and bigger
and more more profitable
and that's why it's happening so
basically they should
fire their agencies then no
i don't think it's their agency's fault
i think it's their fault
right they agencies aren't stealing
their money
they're giving the agencies the money
that's true so i think what should
happen
is we should start changing the way we
compensate
the c-suite of the biggest companies in
the world
because all of them are making decisions
based on what the stock price is when
they leave
so they can liquidate and buy their
yacht not
if red bull's going to be around for 30
years
damn and you know what's funny
yeah they all know it
i was watching you guys all know it i
know i'm i mean i know i'm right
and you know i'm right now that doesn't
mean anything
doesn't mean it's going to change it
just means there's an opportunity
right when when companies that have a
lot more money than you
are throwing 95 of their money directly
in the garbage
you have a chance of winning wine.com
had 114 million dollars in fundraising
when i had 14 000
in advertising in 1997. i beat them
why because i did the right thing for
the business
not because i was an executive trying to
maximize my personal wealth
right do you then think that like
entrepreneurs and small businesses have
a bigger chance to win now than ever
because 100
yeah that it's happening this is not me
predicting the [ __ ] do you think has
happened in the last 10 years
this is the greatest era because because
money
if you're compe let's say you want to
start a toothpaste brand
you're passionate about toothpaste you
want to make more all natural toothpaste
and you want to sell it you can now sell
that direct to consumer
at scale at a level we've never seen
before but if you wanted to start that
25 years ago
the amount of money you had to pay tesco
or sainsbury or walmart just for trade
dollars distribution driving
like of course and then if you actually
run snapchat and instagram and facebook
influencer ads
instead of billboards or print or direct
mail i mean absolutely this is an
incredible time to act like an
entrepreneur whether you're an
entrepreneur
or a corporation right and when i say
act like an entrepreneur
you're scared you know the reason i
became a great marketer
was because the marketing was for my
dad's liquor store and that's how my
family ate
i wasn't going for canned lion awards i
wasn't looking at reports every 90 days
that were metrics on the brand health
lift
this was about [ __ ] selling pinot
noir
and uh and so i got very disciplined
that marketing how to do something for
you
not make you feel good about justifying
that you're a cmo
right and i saw you visited south um
canlines
this year um just like other other
big agencies so the things you're you're
preaching and you're communicating to us
today
um how i mean
acting like all the others going to can
having meetings having parties all that
kind of things how do you make sure that
your whole company are
kind of communicating the same things
you are doing and making them understand
how to prioritize or the client's
budgets
in a different way dictatorship
sounds like fun it is fun i mean
especially when when you're pushing good
yeah
you know it's super fun if i if i see
tendencies from a leader eric here who's
in the front who runs our
you know uk office and most of our
european activities if
if i get any indication that eric is
pushing something that is in
the short-term value of vaynermedia
because he wants the p l of the london
office to look better
and he knows that the client will buy
this but it's not
on message he won't have a job and he
knows that
and it's not that's not bad that's just
to make sure we don't
lose like to me i'm not scared to go to
conferences and have a party
like to me that's a framework what comes
that's like you know that's like being a
human being we're all the same
it's about what's coming out of our
mouths and what our actions are you know
i am met with a lot of cynicism yeah you
said it
you expect watch it you'll love this how
many people here when they first saw me
um or consume my content thought i was a
douche bag or completely full of [ __ ]
raise your hands
right so like i'm aware of that and the
good news is that doesn't [ __ ] me
because either i can deliver or i can't
either you're right or i'm right
and that's kind of how i feel about
vayner right like i'm not worried about
going to can because i go to can and
have this conversation
yeah you know the the qual you know so
like you know having sizzle or looking
like everybody else in the front
is irrelevant it's the execution of the
back end
that is going to ultimately be the case
right
when you and i took that picture years
ago i was amongst
other social media experts that were
charlatans that were going to take
opportunity in this short window i
laughed because i was already a 33 year
old businessman who'd already built an
actual business
i wasn't a real estate agent six months
earlier right
i just truly believed that the attention
of
all these people was going to be in
these things i you know
there's videos of me you know in 2013 a
hell of a lot chubbier
saying like snapchat's gonna happen
either i'm right or i'm wrong this is
not you know super complicated
i said here it's on video that voice is
gonna matter and all of you are gonna
interact with speakers in four years
and if you don't people are gonna pull
up those videos and say don't listen to
gary
look how wrong he's been so i don't
predict
i don't you know i every time there's a
new app i don't
i don't do what a lot of other people do
and just say this is going to be big and
hope one of them is
i don't [ __ ] guess i don't hope i
[ __ ] work and i execute
true i like that
um when we tweeted out that you're going
to visit us today i got a lot of
questions about
vaynermedia in europe yes in the nordics
can you maybe share a little bit about
your plans there look i
we have ambition to service the globe
in a 40-year macro and so
uh you know obviously a lot of people in
nordics saw what we did with arctic
startup and
and you know we have we have 10 team
memes coming to helsinki
in january like we're looking at this
part of the world very
feverishly i'm a very big fan of the
time i've spent in the nordics
and i'll be you know look i think a lot
of you do watch my content i don't go to
every place and be like i like you
i do like this play there's a really you
know it's interesting right
so i'm funny with europe because i
disrespect it
because even though i was born in
belarus and born in eastern europe like
there's like i'm a work ethic guy
and i'm very empathetic to like
work-life balance and quality of life
i'm
i don't judge anybody's opinion but like
to in business
i do think work ethic is super hardcore
important
and i think certain parts of the world
have it
too extreme and work too hard and i
think a lot i think new york is one of
them i really do even though i work
harder than them
i can take back a step subjectively and
go that's a lot
right and then there's other parts of
the world that don't work
at all like grease and [ __ ] right like
the you know
and and i'm like you're [ __ ] losers
right and so
but it's been interesting and i've been
to the nordics maybe 12 13 times i think
there's an interesting cadence here
i think there's interesting brands here
i think there's interesting businesses
here and
we have real ambitions um obviously for
people that
followed me the most they saw that i
kind of ran my mouth and said
we'll be in singapore in 2018 uh with
vaynermedia which
i would say is 95 accurate and so we're
looking at
southeast asia very aggressively right
now but
over the next 20 years the vayner brand
will have a flag in
every every sector right every you know
south america and
africa we will be everywhere and so um
we will be here cool timing i don't know
cool um so i started referring to
the jab jab method when i work with my
clients focusing on giving value earning
the right to market
is that a still a very important thing
to focus on in your opinion and what are
the
big lines of advice you usually give to
your clients like
high level for a lot of people that
don't know i wrote a book several years
ago called jab jab jab
right hook give give give and then ask
i think a lot of people when they put
out content are ask
ask ask ask or take take take take right
i think what has really worked for me
and the clients that i've worked with in
the startups that i've worked with is
when you actually give value and a lot
of times people think they're giving
value
but if you look carefully it's selfish
right so these are nuances but
yeah i think i think it's never been
more important to be what i would call
consumer-centric
a lot of people here talk in boardrooms
about being consumer-centric
but advertising in general already is
not consumer-centric
you want to steal my time to tell me how
good your soda
is that's not inherently
consumer-centric
and so more than ever i believe in
empathy
i think empathy is the secret drug
of success in our society both as a
leader
when you're a boss and definitely when
you think about the consumer and i think
that
the trait of empathy that i took from my
mother is
no question maybe outside of
competitiveness that i took from my dad
the core reason why i sit here today and
uh
if anything i would tell you if i wrote
it again i would call it jab jab jab jab
jab jab jab right hook
it's just more important because there's
so much being thrown out right as the
supply of content
and noise grows you have to
differentiate with more value not less
and so again trying to speak to the
people here who've been following me
you've
you've seen in the last 18 months
compared to the prior five years i've
been
more aggressive of putting out free
information
and good content and in written in audio
in video
in multiple shows like i'm going harder
to bring value because i felt like it
was the only way that i could separate
and create the opportunities that i
wanted for myself was basically i
basically think i'm trying to guilt
people
into being interested in what i'm doing
by providing so much more value
with nothing in return that it almost
creates a level of guilt
yeah i see that um
i've noticed that you switched from
you've been
you're a lot more motivational in your
content now than i agree where earlier
i agree and i remember that you said in
an interview once that you were
very afraid of being looked at as a
motivational speaker yes
so what changed i built it another
150 million dollar revenue a year
business and it made me feel good
that if you called me a motivational
speaker i would say that's fine
but have you been paying attention to
the fact that i grew the fastest growing
agency
in the industry in parallel so by
building
an actual business and by actually being
a ceo
and by actually again not just wine
library but now again a second time
building something you know listen it's
not easy to build something from zero
dollars and zero cents
to 150 million dollars in revenue
not valuation in a seven year window
that takes operational skill
and so if you don't see that that's what
i've done well then that's okay
but what has allowed me to be more
motivational
is the lack of fear that that was the
only thing i was doing
i am optimistic so you got more
confidence and
proof a hundred percent i felt like i
had you know
and don't forget how i figured out the
drock thing right yeah he's just filming
me i'm living my life
it's not like i'm doing that i'm not
gary vee is my side hustle
sure you know gary vaynerchuk ceo of a
large enterprise is what i
do and so yes i felt more comfortable
confident
that i could speak a little bit to the
motivation because the truth is it's
really scary
it's you know it's the way i gave this
talk the tactics
are very commoditized it's the mindset
which gets into motivational aspects
that is so imperative because you're
trying to break through
insecurities in individuals that lack
the courage to do something and are
crippled by fear because they're worried
about other people's opinions i'm trying
to
push so hard to i'm basically trying to
be their courage
so they can blame me if they fail which
i'm fine with
i just want them to do yeah and you
think it's easy for people to
to do things they're scared of if they
can blame you at the end if it didn't
work 100
i really mean that yeah like i and i'm
i'm okay with that because
i think that if i think that people
don't understand
how much they're going to regret when
they're older
i also think a lot of executives here
are going to get fired in six years for
being conservative
even though that's what their company's
telling them to do they're going to be
the fall guy
and the fall gal when the company starts
faltering just like the cmo
of under armour was just pushed out
yesterday
i met with him he was very conservative
the company was telling him to be
conservative
but when it hurt under armour he's the
one that's getting killed
not the ceo so a bunch of people here
are going to be out of a job they think
they're being smart and a political
animal
and they're going to get promoted what
they don't realize is that the market's
changing on them
and when everybody looks at them and
they were the ones pushing [ __ ]
because the company wanted them to pull
[ __ ] they're gonna get fired and i
don't want that to happen to them
so i'm trying to get them to die on
their sword instead of somebody else's
and i'm trying to focus on getting them
to tell the truth instead of what they
think they need to do to get another
bonus this year
cool thank you and the reason they're
clapping is they know how true what i
just said was
yes and you're clapping yet conflicted
and i'm empathetic i don't think i'm
cool i don't think you're bad i'm just
want to have these conversations so you
can be thoughtful
right like maybe it's time to have the
courage to say what you actually believe
because let me tell you something
getting killed on somebody else's thesis
sucks
you'd rather go down with yours
and it's it's the big one yeah it's the
big one yeah it's the one that
again that's why the reaction happened
if i can just give people
courage to go into a meeting tomorrow
and go you know what
first of all they may not have the skill
set of understanding facebook or
snapchat filters or whatever it may be
first you got to motivate them to go
home and read and watch
and get educated right but if they're
here at all
they're already ahead of 99 if they even
are here
i've already got you know when i speak
i'm not speaking in the middle of
red square hoping i can convince a
couple russians right
um in conferences where people have
already come you're ready on third base
now it's just which way are you going to
go you're going to go back or is this
the moment you're going to go forward
and i take a huge result i'm flattered
that
i was invited here i feel obligated to
give my best
thoughts and efforts here and so that's
why i speak
and communicate the way i do i'm playing
for legacy i like that
um so i noticed a kind of a pattern
interrupt in in what you've been doing
with with the planet of the apps
so um for those of you guys who don't
know it's it's a show on apple music
um and i would just love your because
it's
more traditional media kind of so i'd
love to just hear your thoughts on
why i did it why did it and if you got
what you wanted
out of it um i got what i wanted out of
it
not all of what i wanted out of it but i
did it because i love doing things that
are win-win
no matter what happens it's why i did
the sneaker yeah
i was going through this and i'll
explain that as well but i'll stay to
your question
the reason i did that is because the
other three people
that were my guests that were my my
mentors
are [ __ ] famous as [ __ ] you know and
uh
and by being the fourth you know by
being ringo
but knowing that i was john or paul
was a very good strategy right i i knew
it was a
subject matter that i had much more
expertise at right
i knew that i was going to be good on
camera because i am good on camera just
i'd never done a television show
and i thought the whole time that apple
would never release it on apple music
because i thought that was awkward why
would you watch a show on apple music we
didn't get
you know i don't like to fight the
consumer as i was saying in the green
room you do what the consumer does
so the whole time you know took a year
after we signed to coming out
the whole time i'm like okay they're
going to create something called apple
they're going to do something with apple
tv or they're going to create apple
entertainment or they're going to buy
netflix like
the whole time i thought there's no
literally to like the week before the
show
aired i'm like there's no way they're
going to distribute this on apple music
so the reason i didn't get everything is
because it was on apple music
and that was awkward they didn't watch
even though it was in every country in
the world
what i did get was in 10 episodes for
hollywood
i put on film that i'm a celebrity i'm a
star
and i'm worth doing business with and
the level of business deals that i've
been offered
to do any business show i want on the
busiest networks in the world has been
remarkable now
ironically
i am so excited about what's going on
with vayner x
you know i bought purewow i created a
holding company vaynermedia
and i think the stakes are so high based
on what i've been talking about with the
opportunity what the holding companies
are doing
then i'm i'm i was about to say i'm
probably i'm not going to do a tv show
next year
like i thought i would uh even though
the offers are better than i could have
even imagined because i have to stay
disciplined and be the operator
because the opportunity is too great and
so i'm going to see that through but
it was great and also i love doing
firsts
apple is going to figure out original
programming
and one day i'll be sitting at bro
i get it respect um
tough crowd huh yeah he better be taking
a [ __ ]
i know i know which is even better i
wish everybody [ __ ] left right now
and went to work
um i uh i uh
i i like that i'll be able to be here in
seven years at this conference
we'll be talking about how all the
networks died and ott one
and i'll be able to make a reference
like yeah you know when i did the first
show on apple
right that has value and that's how i
think so it was all upside
all upside by traditional t if i did a
regular tv show like i was offered a ton
and it failed
for ratings in theory the way this did
yeah
then i'd have nothing here i siphoned
the brand equity
and had and i'm completely on a
different pedestal in hollywood because
i'm with the other famous people i it
was a show that was around my strengths
so i was disproportionately better on it
so it was a win-win it's very smart to
do business things where
there is no downside
so so two seconds about your shoes
before my last question before open up
um literally the same exact thing yeah
sure
it's the first it you know out of a top
ten sneaker brand
it's the first collaboration where an
entrepreneur has a shoe
not an athlete or a musician
if it works then i get to always say
that i had the first business
sneaker right right if it doesn't work
my best friends get to make fun of me
for having a big ego
so last question before we open up for
the audience so you talk a lot about
legacy
yes and you're talking about legacy
being greater than
currency i do what do you mean by that
might rather be remembered as a
tremendous human being than make a
couple extra dollars
i leave money on the table every day way
more than people would realize
like my assistants my admins my lawyers
my agents they're always freaked out
because i make decisions that are gonna
look good when i'm dead
versus making an extra seven million
dollars a year this year
and so i make when i made a hundred
thousand dollars a year i've made it you
know i came from nothing
you know when you're immigrant and you
live in a studio apartment with seven
family members
and you got nothing when your parents
buy you seven
toys your entire life and you had to buy
the rest of them when you went on one
family vacation
in your entire childhood like you're
coming from a different place
so uh you know what like i said when i
made a hundred thousand dollars a year
for the first time when wine library got
bigger i was like
i made it you know so for me i'm not
driven by the money the money will be
there the money's
there now at a level that i am super
excited about i know i want to buy the
jets but it's the chase of trying
far more than it and uh
and i think i was listen when i talk
about what i think i have that's special
i don't think that's an ego or
confidence i think that's
that's giving my parents and being an
immigrant
a pedestal when i talk about being good
i think that's me flattering my parents
what did i do about it
you know my kids my businesses i feel
pride in
me that's my parents work that's
america's capitalism at work that's
being an immigrant at work
i have nothing to do with the admiration
that i have from people
so it keeps me very grounded the reason
i was nice
you know when people meet me is i didn't
do anything i'm the byproduct of sasha
and tamara they should be running around
acting big shots
i'm [ __ ] just you know trying to
deliver on the gifts
and i'm driven completely fueled
completely fueled
on gratitude i'm so grateful for my
circumstances
and that's why i want to give back i
feel guilty the reason i understand how
to guilt is because i feel that guilt
for having such an
unbelievable mother i feel that guilt
for being born
thank you for being
for being born with talents to
communicate that touch people i feel
guilty for
struggling which created a skin
that makes all your opinions matter to
me
and not matter to me at the same time
and so
yeah i really want legacy to be very
honest with you
because i feel like i was built for it
like i you know
i i don't like saying it because it does
sound so douchy
but i think i'll be all time that that
i love that and let me tell you why yeah
cause i haven't even started
i'm 41 years old like i have 40 50 years
of work
to put into the world and and for you
and others here
you've seen what's happened in one year
compared to a year ago
the momentum is so exponential and
that's how it works
right it builds and it builds and what i
have is real
and it's honest and i really genuinely
want to give them 51
because i know what to do with the 49
yeah and i watch everybody else and they
want 80 and they want 90 and they want a
hundred
and that's why i'll beat them i like
that so
you said you had that
i made it moment yeah many many years
ago yep
and do you still have those moments do
you i mean
are you still i know you're grateful but
are you still having those kind of
moments and even that one was kind of
like whatever
like i uh i'm not good at smelling the
roses no
that was but i to your question it's an
interesting thought and i think it
affects people around me that's why i
think about it
for me playing the game is the roses
the process the struggle the failures
is the stuff that gets me going not the
accolades the awards the money
i like the game i liked four sports
teams in america growing up
my baseball team and hockey team won a
championship and i stopped caring
my football team and my basketball team
still haven't and i care quite a bit
that's me i want the climb i
want the struggle and i've been
successful and i think most people are
successful
when they are in it for the right
reasons and if you're an entrepreneur
the right reasons are getting punched in
the face you get punched in the face
every day as an entrepreneur
everything's on you it's lonely
it's very difficult it's been good the
last eight years because the world
economy is good
wait till it gets bad again a lot of
these kids don't know yet
they don't know what it feels like when
the world melts the money dries up and
you still got to survive
and i've been through two of those
cycles already and like i'm looking
forward to the next one i can't wait for
the world to melt
because all the c and d and b players
get eliminated and go get jobs
and i like that that's merit that's
capitalism that's the game
and so i i don't smell the roses when
things happen
because i think i'm smelling the roses
in real time every day
i like that ready for some questions i
am
all right people um can we change the
lighting so we can actually see
all the people as well uh and dominic
i'll give it to you catch
that's fancy um hi gary how are you my
friend
i'm good love you i love you thanks for
the hoodie
yeah one life baby yes thank you
um i'm i'm curious you talk always about
you talk
always about speed yes important very
hiring is important and firing is even
more important
what what is the process in vaynermedia
how long do you
does it take for you to fire a person
somebody's somebody just got approved to
be fired in 90 days today
other people i've been agonizing for 18
months okay
there's no one size fits all right
there's there's two forces there's me
as an individual as the dictator as the
ceo as the leader
and then there's the collective
leadership right yeah and i try to
counterbalance them i don't blindly i
don't
take my leadership's opinions blindly
because they're protecting their lives
and their opportunity and so they may be
doing the wrong thing subconsciously
they're not bad people um so
it runs the gamut i mean there was
somebody i hired
not too long ago that i thought was
going to be important and i basically
fired that person
in my mind 48 hours later okay
so the problem the reason most people
here don't fire when they're supposed to
is their own ego they don't want to
admit that they were wrong in making the
selection of the person
and it is killing so many of your
businesses
or the other reason they don't fire is
somebody's too important to their
business financially
even though they're a cancer internally
which means they're going to lose
long-term too
and so i don't do those two things i
make sure that i'm way better than
everybody that works for me so i'm never
at the mercy of anybody i'm being
serious
and uh and uh and i also
am very humble when it comes to my
i think i have great eq it's what i
trade on
but i've been so wrong so many times
because it's so difficult
and so um they run the gamut
there's a million different things
what's unacceptable
what speeds up people are fired much
quicker
for being not nice to the other boys and
girls
much quicker than not being good at
their job
they can't be disruptive to the energy
the culture
because i don't like tension and
negativity and if you're [ __ ] me up
you got no shot
i like that thank you very much welcome
uh could you sign
yeah of course thank you okay so um rick
i'm throwing it too let's throw
damn thank you in a second i think we
can hear me
yeah gary welcome to oslo thank you so
much my friend
i've got two questions yes my first
question first off i want to say thank
you for talking so much about gratitude
thank you thank you my first question
i'm going to try to make you jealous
go ahead all right i was a 13 year old
boy
i was growing up i was living in west
islip new york yes
january 12th 1969
best thing i got up here six o'clock in
the morning because i couldn't sleep oh
man i'm waiting for a [ __ ] job
in the afternoon what was i doing you
were ready for the new york jets
stunning my friends the sports
illustrated the most important sports
magazine in america at the time
predicted the jets would lose the super
bowl
41 to nothing yeah they were the biggest
underdog
in super bowl history and they won
broadway
joe namath against johnny unitas that's
amazing man that's so cool
so yes i'm actually jealous i brought
you hat
thank you thank you that was the hat you
have a question the second question is
about
voice because i'm really happy you're
talking about voice yeah i just launched
a voice
app which is a voice analysis technology
called voiceable
and what we do with the app is we record
somebody's voice and then we help
speakers and presenters to work on their
voice it's interesting and
this is it is interesting and it allows
you to compare yourself to some of the
greatest speakers and
inspirational speakers so you're
breaking down the analytics of exactly
making it easy to practice with it but
the number one celebrity that you can
compare yourself with
is always barack obama most people want
to do it
but number two is gary garyvee i think
you've got your ratings wrong
no it's i may have i mean
that's amazing so my question is you
gotta see that there's all these
entrepreneurs young entrepreneurs who
are racing around and they want to be
like gary vee
and they're talking fast and they're
trash talking and you know that scares
me right
just scare me and my comment is what
would you have what kind of a comment
would you have to them
i would say for them to be them like i
think you know self-awareness
along with gratitude and along with
empathy is something i'm spending a lot
of time talking about it's funny
i come across so alpha so when i talk
about all these
soft and warm skills i'm always
fascinated by how people consume it
because it's a real curveball right what
i would tell them is they need to deploy
self-awareness
what made me me was i was
brought up with so much self-esteem by a
mother that understood its power
and i had my own dna and circumstances
that
i didn't want to be anybody else i the
level of knowledge i have on richard
branson
or steve jobs or jack welsh or bill
gates or mark i know nothing about
anybody
like zero i've always just focused on
being confident about what i had and
more importantly being humble about what
i didn't have you can't
you know when you try to fabricate
charisma
it comes out as the worst shtick ever
and we can all taste it and so
look i've doubled down and triple down
and quadrupled down and
continued to on what i have um
and so i try to tell a lot of these
young men you know it's been really
interesting for me
i've been spending an ungodly amount of
time on motivation
because i think it's a gateway drug to
get a lot of young men into my funnel
and i think a lot of young men are very
easily swayed to the wrong
things because of insecurities and what
kind of things guys want in their 20s
and i've been very proud about this last
year from a legacy standpoint
of getting so many guys to think i'm
cool because then i systematically break
them down with my content
and instead of being disrespectful and
instead of looking for money
and girls and things of that nature i
start
teaching them tried and true things that
will make them get everything they've
ever wanted
and be a much better contributor to
society
great thank you gary thank you very much
yeah and let's make sure we bring it up
there because i always feel like we
always
mess that up you're right yeah this
happens hey gary
how are you fine thank you very
inspiring to be here thank you
i have a question i do sales training
for business to business
awesome and one of the biggest
challenges for them is to
find the right customers and actually
get enough customer meetings with the
right
clients makes sense i think that's all
over the world about the same problem do
you know why
because most people in b2b sales are
always talking instead of listening
yeah i totally agree the concept is spam
everybody on [ __ ] linkedin
pound them pound and pound them and
nobody wants to talk to them anymore
which is why they don't have enough
meetings instead of engaging
in content that's being put out on
twitter and linkedin
whereas if they say something meaningful
in a comment and looked in
they get asked to have a meeting versus
the other way around
yeah and and the way you talked about
the facebook being underpriced and you
talked about this white paper on
linkedin
what is uh kind of underpriced or right
value
meaning to get in contact with the right
clients
for business to business companies the
reason i love b2b is you know who you're
trying to reach
and so when i said listening i gave you
the tactical way which is people are
putting out content and you can engage
with that content and they'll see you
the much better way to listen is to know
the company you're going after
doing some research for an hour or two
or three days
and understanding what their strengths
and weaknesses are
and then things that people blow me away
for example in my business there's a lot
of people i want to do business with
but if the ceo is best friends with
martin sorell
we're not getting that business and so
i'm stunned by salespeople's inability
to deal in reality
i love when sales people are like i'm
gonna break through no you aren't
[ __ ]
you're gonna waste time and so i think
listening research understanding instead
of blanket
spray and pray high volume cold calls
emails
networking events handing cards it's
just it's not working
it's a waste of time and money sometimes
the math works out i'm not against it i
love the hustle
but a lot more listening and
understanding the score understanding
who you're competing with
and understanding if that product
there's happiness
in the system the reason vayner's grown
so quickly is i
paid attention to who was not happy with
their digital work
i didn't go after br there's a lot of
brands i wish i was working with
cereal is my favorite product and we
don't have a serial client i can't find
the right angle right now
to seeing any of the big cereal brands
upset enough that it's a good
conversation got it yeah so
a lot more the best way to be a great
sales person is to be a listener not a
talker
yeah thank you you're welcome
okay all the way in the back get your
serial killer what's that serial killer
serial killer
somebody has
it's harder
my name's kurt and i'm the president of
one of the universities here in
in oslo and uh university education is a
dying industry we're slaves to the
campus model
our government cares only about getting
people through fast enough
correct uh i assume you think education
is a good idea but do you see any value
for
degrees i do see value for degrees in
the short and medium term
if people have a very specific job they
want and that organization
requires a degree to get if you want to
be a consultant at bain and mckenzie
in the next 24 to 36 months i still
believe that they care about where you
went to college however
and you can hold on to the mic because i
think we might have a good conversation
here
however to your question that you're
leading i think you're barking up the
right tree
i don't think that people realize that
the biggest and best universities in the
world
are only trading on brand right not on
the actual education
that that actual education is actually
sitting at the professor level
not at the university or campus level
and as education gets commodity
you know distribution of education gets
commoditized and things like khan
academy and the seven other things that
are about to happen
if you get the 13 best professors of
economics together
if i if i as a great businessman went
out
and rounded up the 13 best professors
around economics
and created a direct to consumer
economics
training education platform we would
dominate
we would dominate we would win because
that's where the ip is
it's in her and him not at the logo
level and so
i think i think over the next 20 to 30
years
this great run of 100 years plus
is coming thousand years respect respect
because i'm undereducated
this great run it's true i am i to your
point
is clearly in a vulnerable place um and
i think every country has its own
dynamics
my answer was you know in america you
started getting into the 50s when
everybody had to go to college or a
community college
not go vocational right so there's
different dynamics
different cultures will spend their time
differently
in dissolving this but i think your
energy is right
i think when somebody watches this video
in 50 years they're going to say wow
those guys got it
those guys got it yeah because you know
uh all we really need to do at the
institutional level is
in a sense uh double check and give
accreditation to all the crazy online
work experience combination of things
that put
the people put together to make an
education and don't forget and don't
forget that's just
playing on the brand right putting that
certainly approval is just brand
and and sharing the quality but the idea
that we're going to draw everybody to
move on to campus for five years to get
educated
that's crazy and listen listen the
counter argument people say well people
have grown up on these campuses and i go
i agree but listen travel around the
world then try
you know like there's so many
alternatives to putting them on campus
where they can learn to mature as
individuals you know
i mean you're preaching to the choir on
this one
um i uh i think it plays out
uh but of course learning is imperative
but like you know for me
you know entrepreneurship is probably
the one that is most intriguing to me
because the thought of learning
entrepreneurship in a classroom
versus being in the field is just so
ludicrous
and then america has a weird extra
dynamic the level of debt
our citizens are going into you've got
23 year olds coming out of college today
with 280 000 in debt at enormously high
interest rates
and the piece of paper is not getting
them a good job anymore
i mean it's really bad in america really
bad and ironically it's the one thing
you can't declare bankruptcy from
and clear up you can literally be
fraudulent
and clean up your credit but you can't
do it with a college
debt i mean it's it's such a [ __ ]
fraud it makes me throw up
yeah that's right me too and yeah
unfortunately gary um we're out of time
for questions
really yeah and the organizers are
really strict about time
but can we sneak maybe one more in yeah
let's be ready let's do that [ __ ] that
last question
okay clearly okay okay this guy
obviously
wow that was good marketing yeah strong
feelings i'm telling you sound is on
voice baby oh thank you so much
okay hi gary we hi frederick b
uh it's an honor to talk to you pleasure
um you're was
you were talking about google and the
possibility to do a deal as good as a
steal
then it was facebook which emerging
platforms do you see with the biggest
potential
for a steal deal right now alexa skills
and briefings
thank you you're welcome and let me give
you guys why that that plays out i
believe that if you're
quick to building briefings and skills
and if you don't know the difference
between an alexa skill and alexa
briefing
you literally just google it and in
about 15 minutes you'll know
got it but one is just passive
information one is more ai
and understands they can go back and
forth with you i
look in the same way to your point
snapchat's bigger here than instagram
and things of that nature
i always want to give advice that
matters to you i don't know how the
voice play
plays out in the nordics but here's what
i can tell you it's going to happen
and the quicker you understand the
theoretical
strategies behind it when your thing
happens
you'll be able to move quicker instead
of debating if it's going to happen
and that's why i think that's the most
and i don't usually
guess or i don't by day trading
attention you don't know what's coming
next you don't care you only care about
today
but to to give you an insight i do
believe that is the clear black and
white
emerging space in our society
nice amazing thank you you're welcome
okay so i'm just going to give you some
practical information norwegian so bear
with us and then i'm going to
thank you and we're going to give you a
nice applause great
um okay i'll check my phone yeah do that
uh
[Music]
i'm gonna watch a movie so two seconds
that's what i thought
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay everybody thank you
thank you so much for coming and let's
give gary a big applause
thank you thank you
and have a great day thank you
thank you
[Music]
leave your four cents two points two
bullets from what you saw
in the comments and subscribe subscribe
subscribe so many of you being lazy
anyway nonetheless leave your four cents
uh
two bullet points in the comments now
[Music]
you